yeah hello welcome to this video this is
a rabid game again twenty five ten
twenty five minutes ten second increment
yeah I went 124 and let's see what we
are going to get g66 c5 did I play Pearl
hacker before it seems kind of unknown
name it didn't plane before ok I can do
Agee 5 which probably gets the Benoni or
the bangko but let's let's do 90 of 3m
go to an English opening just for
something else this is an interesting
move autumn idea that I want to
investigate in the future it's rather
useful to play this precise position
because you can also get it from 93 9 f6
c4 c5 and then d 4 which is quite useful
if you are able to play that in water as
it prevents certain lines from the black
side the Hedgehog for example I mean
black can still try for an hand shock
wire b6 now but this is not particularly
threatening in comparison to other
hedgehogs as I can go F 384 quickly and
sis believed to be rather careful white
one argument against this particular
move water which is questionable if it's
really an argument against it is to move
45 after which night b5 is threatening
96 check and black will then go D Phi
for gambit maybe we will see that move I
mean it's what people quite frequently
play here especially if it comes from
that benko type of move order or benoni
move order as we head here and he's
going for that
so might be five it's the most
aggressive continuation and this kind of
fits with the approach of the bangko on
benoni yet d hive now is the move that
they play and then cd5 it's important to
see that night XD 5 is answered by Queen
takes d5 and black resigns yeah
blundering a whole piece so after d5 cd5
they play Bishop to c5 and play this
position upon down let's say form quick
development whatever white has an extra
pawn on d5 so it's like that's uncommon
that's uncommon so let's think about
this for a moment what is the idea I
mean Bishop t2 he will not take this
would be strategically very dubious you
will probably play after Bishop t2 will
probably play Bishop c5
I have before then however before should
be seven very weird stuff of course I
can also i can just play one night one
to see three now that looks rather
rather natural after a six i have 96
check and if he castles i will probably
just go a three yeah that's probably the
most turn the most fluent way to develop
bishop d2 and then Bishop e7 didn't look
that great i mean not like bad for white
but now after 93 now i'm not quite sure
how it's going to complete his own
development here without being am
settled with that somewhat questionable
structure in the center yeah 96 now what
is the big deal ok at least I can play
that move quickly King e7 i have 9 a-5
amongst others and then i will play ok
he just takes and now Queen to e7 ok
this is something that you can do it
it's not very attractive but he can
definitely em play that ok let's say if
I take and go Bishop g5 I have this
immediate threat of 95 which is really
awkward already
yeah he almost has to play Queenie so I
mean Knight to c6 looks mmm looks rather
awkward 96 96 95 it's not yet working I
think okay it's doing this but I can
take on e 7 and play Bishop g5 and I
don't really see what is doing against
95 check that already is very awkward I
mean this be 67 weaknesses they are a
huge issue one of the and safe app
remove certain Bishop g5 yeah well d 695
he just loses the house I mean this will
this will at least cost a pawn and a
very valuable one they have six pawn I
mean f6 after I've taken years of the
Jeep on it is currently yeah 95 I don't
see him clear ok you can we can retreat
app king da tore something liking f8 I'm
sorry I can take on 95 we have a denial
i put my night on b6 and then castle
long is a disaster
you have this one here i have g3 as a as
a promising move i can also just take on
f6 i mean if i take on f6 king cheeks 95
check it sir i mean i'm getting to be
six then with my night and I'm going to
Castle long this is really really really
terrible g3 however is also a pretty
strong move Bishop h3 is quite quite
unsettling d6 Bishop h3 check kiki is
795 check and black totally falls apart
but should have 60 ever is a simple and
strong hmm Bishop f6 GF 95 hmm group is
7 immediately Knight b6 then he gets in
d6 mean that's not not so clear so I'm
going to go for the cheese dream that
that is a good move also follows that
almost them universal logic and chance
that if you can introduce a new piece
into the game with a gain of tempo which
bishop s recheck certainly looks like if
you can do that it's almost all of the
time it's it's the best move on one of
the best moves so let's go for it d6
Bishop re-check king is 795 check-in d8
there is some Bishop takes see a
twinning material
yeah I don't really know what to what is
move was him okay so um should age three
I guess huh jack kini 795 check well
that is not very testing which came to
d6 i'm probably going to casa long
yeah going to castle mall anything
better even I mean it look so awkward
them now let me jack it's ready enough
so why is it going to to c5 ya know okay
so here I can check f6 and go 495 check
just one less the immediate 95 any
better may I can take I mean that's
probably not a good idea to allow but
this is a good thing here just this a 95
check and I will need to pre move when
we have some time Jack and I'm not
really thinking about grabbing on f6
then much I'm more interested in yeah
Knight b6 here getting a position where
he sir where is ruckus stalemated there
on on a seven this is there
that's through there this is the bigger
the bigger fish to catch that look down
yeah okay seven and now am I taking on
d7 with the bishop I don't really like
to develop his bishops in a way by
trading it but this thing is the thing
is it seems completely winning shrimp de
semana heap he basically has to take a
druggie several and then the some rukon
a seven is so stalemated you can try
some a five
no it still seems seems pretty pretty
strong um can I can also start with
something like c5
yeah there's really no particular point
so i can take on d7 here if he goes King
c7 I can take on c aid so he basically
has to I come on let's not let's not
pretty move him it's really no need it
takes i mean i can actually also stick
with the night and grab a second pawn
it's not too bad but okay it just looks
right to put that hook on the
seventh-ranked it's just so strong and
have a very clear idea look HD one route
takes f7 rook 1d seven run this flows
very black resigns yeah yeah
understandably answer sir a really
disastrous position okay let's go back
here yeah this some this line here um
ticks ticks and now as i said 'i five is
in fact the move that is played most
frequently by the aggressive players of
the ideas than here while he went with
this check which i didn't know i mean
maybe it is not that terrible but the
the normal way to procedure is d5 and
after cd5 as i said this is not on loses
a whole piece due to that check fork
trick so Bishop c5 is what they do and
here i think i will d 6 is a well-known
mistake after castles 97 like has this
reply and will ya will essentially
almost win the game but white has other
ideas of course i can go a three here or
i can immediately go back and to play
something with g3 a.m. i'm not i'm sorry
a slight cold I'm not um and then well
informed him and just wanted to try it
out I think g3 is a move and black gown
is supposed to have
compensation for the pawn I'm not
entirely sure about it I mean this has
been a frequent own um subject of
discussion in in young Gustafsson's
opening videos for chest 24 and young
keeps mentioning that he believes that
white is better here um yeah maybe maybe
is I really don't turn know that much
them but I wanted to try it out so okay
he gave that check this and then bishop
is haven't looked a bit wrong here i
didn't really felt I have something
great now I mean if he gets in d5
completely unpunished then this is
looking rather nice actually for him and
here I'm not quite sure what I am
supposed to do maybe this is a move ya
know d5 it's probably not not sufficient
oops that was a bit much check yeah
maybe this is an alternative but I think
one nite nite 12 c 3 cannot be a bad
choice and yeah he went a six now which
seems a bit cooperative let's say I mean
96 is my idea anyway and I will
sometimes play it let's say he goes with
knight c6 even here I can consider 96
maybe I go a three year rather than that
but a success is helping me um I one day
I what it says mean maybe he can cancel
him I was thinking that this is
something that i can always some always
do which should be a slight advantage at
least somehow in those pawns here with
the pawn on d6 they are slightly weakish
ok this was played Jack yellow yeah this
is maybe not that terrible I mean this
is in fact not such a bad development
for black I mean II can maybe go Rupe
285 as an idea and they were check here
which I maybe would have played I'm not
entirely sure then that night on f5 can
also be a liability of course playing
those King moves is not particularly
ideal but yeah it's not all roses for
white either i mean the night on f5
sitting into a tent city i'm sitting
there to be hit by a move like d5 maybe
i'm i'm supposed to drop back and then
go for something like this I'm not
really feeling this in any way because
if black gives up its dark squared
bishop those some squares and then porn
say that they are very very weak yeah mo
ke took them and after after this I
think it already is very very difficult
for like to get some kind of position
that you can play went here check Joe
the engine already says white is winning
here plus 1.6 it's pretty it's a pretty
tap verdict for a position that is still
equal on material terms but what is
black supposed to do an engine gives
king of a Tesla I'm relatively best move
giant is a disaster any computer wants
to go g3 but I can also just take and go
95 the thing is I mean just just imagine
this kind of position here this isn't is
a complete disaster black black is now
I'm almost forced to play d 6 I mean
otherwise I'll put a roof on the six and
then it's completely completely
paralyzed and so he has to drop one pawn
and then we just continue with this
position where white is a pawn up a
healthy pawn up now it's a it's probably
already unplayable g3 is the best
according to the engine that's good I
went with that teria check launched an
assault check out that that's all number
one engine moves up to here okaii seven
and Bishop d7 here and here a comp is on
plus three point seven yeah it is a bit
is a disaster really I mean this is
completely paralyzed and I have very
easy moves through t1 possibly take me
on f7 get the other look into the game
and install a Kiki really cannot cannot
move plus M upon up already and then I'm
picking up a second or third porn rather
rather quickly um yeah this um this move
here can be a very good idea if you are
not such a big fan of the Benoni
structures or or the or the bank or
gambit um in both openings black is some
getting some kind of activity and with
this fianchetto and in the bangko the
queenside pressure that widest often no
sustained to if you don't really want
that then Knight f3 is an interesting
option to transpose to these English
opening structures 96 g6 black has a
huge choice yet this is something you
need to be aware of its not just d5 not
just a 5 I can also go esox or 96 or g6
all those Musa are decent I mean in in
any case and white has some ways to to
play for for an advantage job I mean
test black let's say but they're all a
little bit different and as it is
typical for the English opening it is
rather move order sensitive there is
some really a difference of black place
96 or e6 for example now this for
example is a pretty standard position
where white can play g3a3 various things
but it's a difference if you start with
e 6 here or with 96 now for example
after e6 and white can play 93 of course
but also g3 here for example d5 is also
a rather decent move or Bishop b4 not is
a decent move as well however after this
Knight c3 this is an entirely different
story there so defy this no Bishop
before but black has not played e6 which
means that he can actually go g6 if he
likes and all of a sudden via in amarok
see very interesting move order issues
there so if you intend to decline there
let's say benko and beam only options
here it's not really a way to reduce
your theoretical workload you still have
to look at
but it leads two entirely different
position types which can be a good
choice against the aggressively minded
player because black does not get that
aggressive play out of the English
normally with on the black side okay
well thanks for watching that video